in New York ranked wealthiest city on
the planet with 340 000 millionaires has
the highest concentration of Resident
millionaires at 340 Tokyo San Francisco
Bay Area followed in second and third
place respectively London dropped to
fourth place on the list with 258 and
followed by Singapore to 240 000 the
report focused on people with networks
of million dollars or more the ultra
wealthy lost 10 trillion dollars um or
10 from their net worth of 2022 driven
by global economic uncertainty the
energy crisis and the war in Ukraine New
York is also the home of the most centi
millionaires 100 million plus while San
Francisco Bay area is home to the most
billionaires globally China's hang Zoo
uh Hangzhou topped the list of the
fastest growing cities when it comes to
resident millionaires over the past
decade with millionaire growth of 105 so
um
if in New York City Rob if you can pull
it up let's pick a city okay let's pick
a city go to realtor.com okay go to
realtor.com and let's do
um New York City just type in New York
City okay and uh yeah New York City and
go up and properly are you on rent or
you're on buy click on rent all the way
at the top go on rent yeah so New York
City search that let's see what rent is
like in New York City all right zoom in
right there let's see what that looks
like three to seven thousand thirty six
hundred for a 427 square foot place a
studio by the way this is 427. nuts this
is like 427 square feet so this in New
York is 3 700 the second one you're
paying 4 800 for a 494 square foot uh
space okay keep going lower let's just
see what okay 63rd Street is right up
with Central Park Central Park starts at
59th dude so let's look at the cheap one
right there that one is what 2600 you
have to live in the kitchen though you
see that you have to live in the kitchen
keep going down keep going down with
rent to see what it looks like five
thousand three thousand starters 38
38.95 for 375 foot
square foot Place 42 see that building
to the left that looks like a a uh that
looks like a lot of different things but
that's a commentary in Cleveland yeah
built 352 square foot Place guys this is
352 square feet let me say this one more
time this room is 352 square feet so
you're in the studio room this could be
400 square feet you would pay 4 200 for
this in New York City no so you have to
be a millionaire in New York City to
barely budge make it make your studio if
you're not you got to live like a an
hour out 30 minutes out and that's
including the traffic have roommates in
that little room like hey guys if you
got that corner you got this point at
this corner here we go I know people
that literally do that or you build a
fake wall well it's a thousand bucks
between two bedrooms I've seen it all oh
wild with you I love New York City I
already have roommates yeah I'm listen
I'm from Yonkers New York I'm not I'm
happy in Florida I'm about to go to but
listen here's what I like you know what
I love about New York there's something
about the Yankees right there's
something about you know when I think
about baseball cards I think about New
York Yankees Mickey Mantle I think about
steinburner that's an owner to me when I
think about owners I think two names him
and Jerry bus those are the guys that
just just set the tone with what they
did right uh the city the fight the dog
fight the culture that whole thing yeah
you would look forward to going I'm
about to go to New York in a couple
weeks by the way you know the top
restaurant there 11 Madison right the
the guy unreasonable Hospitality that is
they're they're doing 18 million year
One Restaurant okay turning into the
number one restaurant in the world three
Michelin star there's so many things you
can sell about this place here's the
crazy part you realize if New York City
got a governor
that ran for eight years and he cleaned
house with taxes he cleaned the streets
and made it safer he made it great for
startups to go there he actually
invested into police and encouraged the
mayor students invest in police and he
cleaned the place up you realize good
luck everybody else yeah that's how
great of a place that place is but
unfortunately nobody is saying anything
about the people of New York the fight
of New York the DNA of New York anytime
I got a sales guy recruited in L.A in
Texas anywhere that was from New York I
preferred it because you can challenge
him you can push him you can kick his
ass he didn't give a matter of fact
he did better the more you did that with
him there's a certain energy about
people from New York they negotiate in a
more straight up way they're just kind
of like hey here's how we do this no
problem it saves a lot of time versus
well let me tell you it's a very easy
way to do business but unfortunately you
know what they're doing right now it's
not it's not not slowing down so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]